(electronic music)
- What, no?
(phone ringing)
Come on.
Come the fuck on!
(phone ringing)
- Oh my God, finally.
Where the fuck are you?
- I'm stuck!
I'm stuck in an elevator!
The service is terrible!
- You're in an elevator?
Why would you go
into a big building,
today of all days?
Abby, it's Inauguration Day!
- I know, I'm sorry, okay?
It was the last voucher
for my laser hair removal.
- Abby, it is about to get
I Am Legend up in here.
You're gonna need
those pubes for warmth.
- I know, dude.
But I prepaid for the package!
What am I not gonna
finish a package?
I'm sorry,
I don't want a mustache
for the apocalypse.
- Mustaches are gonna
be currency soon!
- I mean, it's gonna grow back.
Laser like hardly works on me.
- I know I thinkit's
about the equipment,
and the settings
more importantly.
- Okay, okay, okay.
It's happening.
We are T-minus 60 seconds
until (bleep) is inaugurated.
- I can't believe it.
Oh my God!
Okay, okay, you know what?
Your elevator's gonna
start moving soon,
and we'll meet
somewhere in the middle.
Maybe where that Jew tried
to grab your pussy, okay?
- Okay, I hate that spot.
But okay.
Alright, do you have mace?
- Yeah, do you have
your butterfly knife?
- Yeah, it's in my other hand!
- Good.
- Okay, okay, we're
30 seconds out.
Fuck!
- Abby, I love you.
I love you so much,
whatever happens I love you,
and on the way,
if you could loot you
know batteries or food,
I kinda forgot,
I forgot batteries
and food.
- 15 seconds!
- Oh my God!
- Remember what we learned
in Krav Maga, okay?
Eyes, nose, throat,
(chanting together)
kneecaps, groin, feet.
Eyes, Nose, Throat,
Kneecaps, Groin, Feet!
Okay, Three.
Two.
One!
(elevator moves)
- No, Abby, no!
- Oh, no, no, no!
Dude, my elevator's
just working again.
It's just working again!
- What's it like?
(opens curtain)
(screams)
Holy shit!
- What is it?!
- Dude, SVU's filming
outside my apartment!
They never film down here,
nothing does!
- Oh my God!
Is Mariska there?
- I can't see, I
wanna go check it out.
I wish you were here.
- Me too.
(pants)
(phones beep)
(elevator music)
(in unison) Fuck!
- Fuck, dude!
(in unison) Fucking (bleep)!
Fuck me in the fucking face!
- This is what
we're living in now!
- Fuck me!
Woman hating, fucking
daughter-fucking--
- This is bad!
- Twitter bitch!
- These are (bleep) times!
- Fuck me!
- (Bleep) times call
for (bleep) measures!
- Fuckin' braggin' about
sexual assault, mother fucker,
Billy Bush is a
fucking butt plug!
- People are just
gonna be grabbing shit!
- Dude Pence, he's
like a fucking wooden
doll from the 50s!
- We're gonna have
to wear cups now!
- His cum is like orange slime--
- People are just gonna
be peeing on other people!
- Fuck me, man--
- Foaming at the mouth now--
- The fucking worst part
is he's actually sick,
he's just mentally ill,
it's not even funny.
(elevator music)
- So, I think I'm just
gonna come over still?
- Yeah, and you know what?
We'll just google how to google
our local representatives.
- Okay, good plan.
I'll be there in like,
today, hopefully.
- Okay, I'll see
you in a little bit.
Love you, baby.
- Love you too.
(electronic music)